bonjour merci avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors une loi qui fait polémique
pourquoi un nouveau texte
est-ce que l'arsenal juridique en france
ne suffit pas l'arsenal juridique ne
suffit certainement pas en france
actuellement
mais par contre ce texte vient un très
mauvais moment dans un très mauvais
contexte est ce que je déplore
est-ce qu'on voit dès cet après midi et
sur les samedis précédents
c'est finalement le gouvernement le
président emmanuel macron renvoie dos à
dos des manifestants qui ont toute
légitimité légitimité pardon à
manifester avec des commerçants qui on
connaît la situation sont dans une
situation extrêmement difficile et voit
d'un très mauvais oeil
bien évidemment les manifestations qui
pas y avoir en province dans les centres
villes alors on les a un mobilisation
nous qu'aujourd'hui c'est le troisième
samedi de suite est ce que vous
comprenez que les manifestants ne se
sont pas écoutés par l'exécutif mais
c'est une telle évidence les
manifestants ne sont pas écouter les
parlementaires ne sont pas écoutés
manifestement le gouvernement a joué
avec le feu le président emmanuel macron
a joué avec le feu sur cette histoire
avec la loi sécurité globale qui vient
quand même avant qu'une commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur le sujet des
pratiques policières et rendu son
verdict donc encore une fois en marche
complètement sur le parlement on
n'écoute personne
on propose
mouvaux de la sécurité au mois de
janvier
et en attendant on a une situation
déplorable il ya qu une seule chose à
faire aujourd'hui de la part du
président la république c'est les voies
de l'apaisement et les voies de
l'apaisement ça passe par deux choses
immédiate
1 le retrait de ce texte de loi sécurité
globale d'abord qu'il n'est pas bon et
qui a été fait à lattes et ensuite bien
évidemment la démission du préfet de
police de paris
parce que on a plus dans la capitale la
possibilité de manifester dans des
conditions sereines y est normal et ça
c'est tout à fait inadmissible dans un
pays comme la france nous vous comprenez
le collectif stop la sécurité globale
qui a appelé à des mobilisations en
région et pas à paris c'est d'une
certaine manière montré un sens de la
responsabilité mais en face je vous le
disais tout à l'heure la problématique
c'est que c'est ça le gouvernement joue
là dessus et je trouve ça terrible c'est
que c'est renvoyé les manifestants en
face des commerçants et des gens qui ont
besoin d'aller faire leurs achats de
noël et vraiment je trouve que c'est
dramatique c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau c'est quelque chose qui pouvait
être anticipée
donc il ya quelque chose de volontaire
autour de cette stratégie du
gouvernement de mettre dos à dos
différentes catégories de français en ce
moment je crois vraiment qu'on a autre
chose à faire et il ya une voie
d'apaisement à trouver et en urgence
maintenant et moins pour l'instant
j'entends pas les bons signaux de ce
côté alors pour la teneur de cette lan
rappelle un a jugée liberticide par les
organisations de défense de droits de
l'homme mais aussi par les syndicats de
journalistes vous les comprenez mais
bien sûr
elle est liberticide mais est-ce qu'il
faut voir en plus c'est qu'elle
s'inscrit dans quelque chose de beaucoup
plus large
vous avez un décret du 2 décembre donc
c'est pas quelque chose qui passe au
niveau de la loi qui modifie le code de
la sécurité intérieure à partir de
maintenant on pourra être fichés non
plus pour pour nos activités mais pour
nos opinions politiques
enfin c'est gravissime ce qui est en
train de se passer et puis si on regarde
par ailleurs il ya une loi de
programmation et d'orientation de la
recherche est dedans qu'est ce qu'on
trouve la pénalisation des manifestants
des étudiants éventuellement sur les
sites universitaires
donc c'est un mouvement d'ensemble vous
comprenez c'est ça qui se passe et de la
même manière quand on regarde que
finalement la la reconnaissance faciale
est autorisé de facto alors qu'il ya eu
aucun débat démocratique sur cette
question c'est ce contexte général qui
fait que une loi comme celle là qui
vient à ce moment là elle est tout à
fait inadmissible et son contenu est
extrêmement inquiétant et il faut
revenir dessus très clairement la
plupart des oppositions se cristallise
sur l'article 24 mai c'est l'ensemble de
la loi aujourd'hui dont vous demander le
retrait oui c'est l'ensemble de la loi
parce que c'est c'est à la fois cet
article mais enfin quand on regarde au
niveau des drones ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe comme autorisation de
surveillance sur internet
en parallèle on se dit on va vers une
société de la surveillance de masse et
permanence et partout et donc il ya cet
esprit-là contre lequel si c'est ça
comme modèle de société qu'on veut
il faut que ce soit débattue il faut que
ce soit discutée largement et pas que ce
soit une discussion à l'emporte-pièce
une loi bâclée à lattes pendant l'été
qu'on va positionner là pour faire
plaisir au nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur c'est pas acceptable ça
sébastien nadeau merci d'avoir répondu
hein
question je rappelle que vous êtes
député non-inscrit de la 2e
circonscription de haute garonne mercier